Một qua mục mạng 3 năm 2020, các quan tính rất đều trạc công an tính bắt ninh đã hử tụi của an,
hợi tổ bị cân và rất lệnh tạm ra đều với phần văn bình, 3, 2 tuổi, chú phần tính tính bắt ninh,
về tội hình hả vội còn.
Chứ đó, ngày 2 mệt tự thằng 2 năm 2020, công an phần tính tính tính tính tính tính tính bảo về việc,
sau phân thị một tế, mấy bắt tuổi, bị bố đẻ là phần văn bình choi và dùng tài.
Trân, chở quên nhà đánh người thương tích, băm tính nhiều chủ trình cơ thịt,
điner xau khi tiếp nhận tính bảo, công an phần tính tính tính đã quên trình được ra.
Sau khi, tệ cơ quan công an, mình thay nhận cho khoảng phần tưởng em ở chiến đến thái
thái thái thái thái thái thái thái thái thái năng thái y khú trong tham sau đã bố lần nánh.
Hình hả con và vợ đung thái là chiến nước thịt tế, 3 bắt tùi, phán thân mình là đu quốc tính câu đầu,
khi vợ vào con đàn chảy với mình là đánh đập hình hả?
Thếng vụ an tức tục được ra làm só?